- Good afternoon and
welcome today's session
on the topic of advancing
behavioral health analytics
with integrated cloud services.
This session will step
through the journey.
The Commonwealth of Virginia
has taken to implement
a modern enterprise data warehouse,
to streamline data management,
improve data quality,
associate individuals across
multiple health systems,
and optimize outcomes reporting
on critical programs serving
our vulnerable populations.
My name is Bryant Jenkins.
I'm the engagement manager
leading the implementation
of the new EDW platform
for the Department of Behavioral Health
and Developmental Services.
I'm joined on stage with three
of our technology leaders
from Virginia and Deloitte
that helps make this transformation
to a serverless event-driven
architecture possible.
Bob Osmond, Russell
Accashian, and Don Hoag.
Gentlemen, could you please
each introduce yourselves.
- Thank you. Good afternoon, everyone.
Bob Osmond, I'm the Commonwealth CIO
and agency head for
the Virginia IT Agency.
- Good afternoon, Russell Accashian,
the chief information officer
for the Department of Behavioral Health
and Developmental Services.
Great to be here.
- I'm good. I got my mic, thanks.
Don Hoag, I'm the Deloitte
leader in digital health
and also am the account manager associated
with this project for Deloitte.
And I did order the extra large room,
but I guess we'll have to
deal with what we got, so.
(all laughing)
- Okay. Thank you, all.
So, now for today's agenda,
we're gonna begin with an overview
of Virginia's IT footprint,
followed by steps
that VITA has taken to transition
on-premise applications
to the AWS cloud.
Then we're gonna spotlight the work
that's been happening over
within DBHDS specifically
to rethink how data is collected,
governed, and aggregated
to support data-driven decisions
related to behavioral and
mental health programs.
- Hey, Bryant. you need
to advance the slide.
- [Bryant] Okay.
- So, states are funny
entities. We're all different.
You know, if you look at, there's 50 of us
and everyone operates with
a different type of model.
Virginia is a mid-size state.
We're smaller than Texas,
bigger than Rhode Island.
We serve 8.7 million citizens.
And as you can see, there's
67 different agencies
that we directly work with.
The breadth of the state
in terms of Virginia
recognizes the diversity
of the respective missions.
And so, if you think about
all the different things
that a state does, we
have entities that operate
museums and cultural exhibits.
We have groups that do public
safety, like the state police.
We have groups that operate,
you know, hospital systems.
We have people that manage transportation.
It really is a breadth of activities.
We even have a space port.
So, when you look at all
these different things,
you see a lot of stuff.
And, you know, we operate in
a 1,700 different locations.
We have a lot of data,
a lot of different
services that are offered,
and that the work that we do
at the state level follows four themes.
One is the work around
commonwealth infrastructure,
so the different things
that people use to
operate their IT systems
for the agencies that we serve.
We provide statewide
unified cybersecurity.
We do governance of all kinds
of IT-related activities
across the state.
And then we do statewide procurement.
Next slide.
So, the operating model that we have
is what I call a shared operating model.
It's very much based around the notion
that at the enterprise we
standardize the infrastructure
so that we can unify the
different work that we do
in terms of the platforms
that we operate in,
the network, the end user compute
devices, the data centers.
Those are all common across
the 67 different entities.
We provide shared work in
terms of the governance
and the architecture
and the cybersecurity.
The work then, but that's
happening at the data
and the application layer
that was very much done
by the agencies that we serve.
And so, this is what I call a
decentralized model, you know.
And like I said, every state
operates a little differently.
At Virginia, this is how we operate
and it's a nice way to drive
scale and standardization
on things that lend
itself to standardization
and also allows agencies that
are closest to their mission
to develop the unique
solutions and capabilities
that they need in order
to deliver that mission
as best possible.
So, we started our journey
really back in 2018.
That's when we got into
the cloud officially.
And I call that phase
between 2018 to 2022 our fake cloud phase.
And so we were in the cloud technically,
but we were using the cloud
really like as if it was
a private data center.
So, we were using EC2 clusters.
We were using storage.
But we weren't really
taking advantage of it.
We were treating 'them as just
another source of servers.
That changed around 2022
when we started looking
at the true opportunity
of working in the cloud.
And that's where we started looking
at all the different
serverless capabilities.
We started looking at the value
of how we can more fully
embrace the public cloud
and work together.
And we started with AWS.
There were a lot of reasons
why we led with AWS.
There's quite issues around...
It was a function of maturity.
It was a function around choice.
For example, in the private
cloud that Virginia had,
we offered 50-ish different
flavors of compute,
different types of operating systems,
different types of clusters.
In the AWS cloud, we offered 450
and that number is growing
and growing and growing.
And even this morning,
they announced even more different choice.
And so, that choice allowed us to think
about cloud capabilities
in a very different way.
Instead of moving, thinking
about it from the perspective
of a server that took
you weeks to provision
to a server that you can
provision in 37 minutes.
That's a very different
mindset around capabilities.
And now that we're looking
at even different types of capabilities
around serverless architectures
and different types of
capabilities in that way,
we're finding that there's
even a greater opportunity
to accelerate value and time to deliver
within the enterprise
and build out capabilities
starting with the fine work
being done by my colleague Russell.
- So, that's a great segue.
Why don't we talk a little
about what's happening over within DBHDS
and the challenges that
you faced when you came?
- Perfect. So, just to
set a little context here.
I probably spent about 25
years in the private sector,
predominantly in the financial services
and in some in healthcare.
I've been with the agency
for about two years.
So kind of brought in that
private sector mentality.
And one of the first things, you know,
that we looked at was, you know,
kind of just an agency topology
and really wanted to understand
kind of where we were.
And what we found was we had
an antiquated architecture.
And there's a lot of companies
out there that have that.
The problem that we
really kind of ran into
was everything in that public
sector is done in silos.
Everything is a funded
project with no vision,
no ability to look at,
well, how do I want to
build, you know, components
that, you know, I can then
continue to build on as I go.
And so, the first thing
that we really wanted to do
was begin to lay out kind of
what we wanted architecturally
and then kind of started with the data.
Everything starts with the data.
And so, we have 12 facilities.
We've got 40 community service boards
that support behavioral health
throughout the State of Virginia.
And then we've got
thousands upon thousands
of private sector supporters
of behavioral health
throughout the state of Virginia as well.
And so, where we're really
trying to to go is understanding
that an individual can go to a facility,
to a community service board,
to a private, you know, provider,
but there was no data
integration across the state
to really understand how this
individual was being serviced.
And so, this is where our
enterprise data warehouse
really began was to start
bringing all of this data in,
building out, you know,
a master patient index
where we could then
begin to track, you know,
the progress of an individual
through the state of Virginia.
We had a lot of manual processes.
It was hard to believe that
data was days, weeks, months
being delayed as you envision, you know,
envision a clinician or a doctor,
you know, servicing somebody
and then having to go in
and manually enter something
because systems weren't integrated.
And so, a lot of what we've been doing
over the last two years, you know,
as we were building
out the data warehouse,
you know, was beginning to
build the integration layers
in the cloud as well
so that as we begin to continue
modernizing our technology,
the hooks are there, the
service bus is there,
the data warehouse is there.
So, now, we are at a position
where we can now
modernize the applications
and continue to integrate
and really begin to move all
these manual processes away.
Last and least was,
there was zero transparency into the data.
Data quality across the
board was truly lacking.
It made it hard to do
analytics to really understand
where the state was, how they were moving
in regards to behavioral health services.
And so, as we sit here today
with millions of transactions flowing in,
we've really, really progressed, you know,
the data analytic capabilities
across the state of Virginia
when it comes to behavioral health.
And we're well positioned now
to really modernize our
technology and move forward.
So, it's been a great partnership.
It was a great, you know, advancement
for the state of Virginia.
And as you'll hear here later, you know,
we're kind of set up to now
begin integrating, you know,
systems across sister
agencies within the state
and that'll be something that'll be done
for the first time as well.
- That's good.
Let's talk about the solution itself.
Don, why don't you tell us about
what made this implementation
of the data warehouse platform
so novel for Virginia?
- And I think it was,
Russell had alluded to it,
and one of the things that
Russell was very clear about
in the beginning of this
and as a part of the
contracting activity was
we don't wanna just do things the same way
that we currently do them.
How do we expand? How
do we get to real time?
How do we get information in more data,
more accurate and complete data?
And so, that was kind of
around three big pillars
that I think about within
the architecture itself
was speed of information.
Can we get APIs?
Do we not just rely
on managed file transfer,
batch information?
But can we create
something that can connect
to these community service boards?
These community service boards,
they use electronic
health record platforms.
And so, integrating with them
and allowing them to submit
information real time,
utilizing cloud capabilities
to expose that secure
and working through key
transfer and key management
so that all that information
can flow very seamlessly.
This was the first time
that DBHDS would also get
accurate and complete
information at the point of care
that was delivered for an individual.
You can imagine all the files
become proprietary files.
The text files, they have to be submitted.
They get corrupted. They don't
have all the data in them.
You have to resubmit them.
Maybe they get fixed. Maybe they don't.
The solution was to solve that,
not only by still
enabling batch submission,
but then also through
a healthcare standard,
the HL7 transaction.
And we went through many
different facets of the pieces
for the discharge information,
the admission information,
like what has to all go into that
so that those community
service boards could give
the department a complete
and total picture
running of everything that's
happened to that person.
You can imagine in the continuum of care,
there are a number of things that happen.
It's not just you go into
a facility and you're done.
You know, there's many follow ups
that happen along that way.
And then the third big piece of this
was also federal compliance.
So, there are many federal
reportings through SAMHSA
and other organizations that are required
to get out to the what is happening.
And it's given DBHDS now
the opportunity to say,
"I have a better understanding
of not only the care
that's being delivered
but how much it's costing,
how frequently it's being delivered."
And we can start talking
about getting proactive
around that care as well
going out in the future.
And I'm sure we'll talk
a bit more about that.
But how have we done that?
Of course we've been focused a lot on
as much serverless
technology as we can get to.
We're trying to ingest real time.
We're also using Glue for
that data transparency
so that we can go through and
say, "Here is the metadata.
Here's the composition of the messages.
Here is the totality of the
pieces that are coming in
and what cycle that they come in."
So there is full lineage of what happens
for every piece, every submission.
We've also now begun ingesting
from financial systems
as well as incorporating master
data management services.
So, we can start looking and saying,
"Are these actually unique individuals?"
So, we're running through an
entity resolution services,
some other verification
functions within the platform
so that we can identify
uniquely each of those people
and then say, "Are we seeing duplicates?
Are we seeing, you know, rationalization
around all of those folks?"
So, that gives us a lot to
that longitudinal record view.
So, now, I can say not only today,
but this month, this year,
these last three years,
what has happened to you
in your entirety of care?
And people can go through
on the front end of the
application, dive into that.
They can drill down.
They can see all the
things that have happened.
There's a very important aspect
here around data quality.
Russell had mentioned a bit
about that as well as Bryant
of saying this transaction process,
it still inherently
has its own challenges.
And so, even though you
get in a record actively,
there may be issues with its submission
that you want the community
service board to fix.
But they need to be able
to log into something
and see the front end and have a dashboard
or something that's going to tell them,
"You've got 10 messages
that failed today,"
or, "You have three data elements
that we expected you to
fill in that you did not.
We're expecting you to now fix that,
get real time acknowledgements,
and have those come back,"
so it's not a month later
that the data comes in
or six months later if they get to it.
There's sort of a running track record now
for those community service boards to say,
"Have you fixed all the things
that we expected you to fix?
Does all the things balance out now?"
10 messages in, 8 errored out.
That means there's two left
you're still supposed to submit.
Have you submitted all of those?
And that running track record,
that learning logging process
as well is actively exposed
to those community service boards.
And they can see those things
so that DBHDS not only
has that transparency,
but so do those active and
accountable participants.
There's certainly any number of things
that we do around some
data enrichment functions.
There's any number of
geocoding activities,
some things that we do
around the diagnosis codes
and procedure codes that are used
with those people at the point of care.
Things that we've had to coordinate
and work directly with those
community service boards
on how is the method
of how you're recording
the care that is delivered
and is that consistent
with how the program anticipates
that that data is being delivered?
So, a lot of reference checks,
verifications that happen in real time,
and then any number of
ingestion integration
into the wider data ecosystem
that Russell wants to
maintain within the department
so that this particular EDW solution
is also one of those supporting components
within the larger enterprise
data ecosystem and framework.
So there's a number of certainly services.
And of course there's compute
and there's various other
things that go into that.
And we can certainly get into
any number of those things,
but I think there's been
an unprecedented amount
of information that is now
available to the department.
There's some exciting things to come next
about what they can start to do
with that information
now that they have it.
If you can imagine historically,
the files that they got were
actually also de-identified.
So they didn't even know who
those individuals per se were
at the, they had like a unique identifier
from that community service board.
Other than that, they didn't have names.
They didn't have anything else.
So some of that security rolled
into working with Bob's team
of how do we make sure now that we have
this accountability around the data
that we're protecting it correctly
and that we have everything
signed and sealed off
the way that it's supposed
to be transmitted,
and supported, and viewed by individuals.
But there was a lot of paving the roadway.
I think that I can
probably go out on a limb
and say that we were one of the first
to really start laying the groundwork
within this environment of how
this could and should work,
not only for DBHDS but also with VITA
and a lot of the surrounding partners.
- So, let's talk about teaming.
Right? This team.
What made this team in
collaboration so successful?
Don, why don't you lead?
But Russell, I'd like
to hear from you after.
- Yeah, I think there was a lot
of even just sort of
group conversations here
around how are we going to
set up the API structure,
how is that going to feed
into a common data ecosystem
and framework that's going to
be shared across applications.
Many Agile sessions
was really a good focus
for how we structured the team
to say we're going to iterate
and we're going to learn
and we're going to, you know,
review and do retrospectives
and come back and have new sprints
that are gonna create different activities
starting with a base foundation
of the data framework.
And then from there we were
able to start progressing
into, like, reporting and activity.
So, that was a lot of
agency department support
around data governance.
What are the policies
that need to be in place,
envisioning what that needs to look like,
and then how security policies
from VITA and team and others
are gonna mix into the
structure and architecture.
A lot of common design
sessions is talk about
what does the framework
and the system solution need to look like
so that it fits with
the architectural plan
but then also the proposed
solution that we had put forward.
So, a lot of very multidisciplinary team.
We have a lot of folks
who are very exposed
to the federal compliance angle of things.
People who are very data focused people,
a lot of technology and
architecture people,
AWS cloud specific people.
And it was, you know, definitely getting
a lot of those people together
and having a lot of good iterations,
but then also solid deliverables
of this is what we're putting forward,
this is what we're recommending, is that,
and then iteration from
all those people on.
We agree. We understand.
This is where we're moving with that.
Thoughts, Russell?
- Yeah, I mean I think for me,
the collaboration was great
but it was something that was different
from being in the private sector
with, you know, where
you owned everything.
- Right.
- You know, 'cause,
like you said, there
was the Deloitte team.
There was an AWS team.
There's the VITA team.
And then I brought on my
chief enterprise architect,
you know, upon joining the
contract was kind of in flight
as we joined.
So, a lot of the groundwork had been laid
and then we had to go
through those iterations
and the collaboration that
you were talking about
to really kind of, you know,
exploit the vision that we had
in regards to what we
wanted to do architecturally
to really advance the agency.
You talked about the real
time data integration.
It was hard to believe
that you had 12 facilities
that, you know, each could have anywhere
from 100 to 300 to 400 beds
and nobody knew what was going on.
- Right. (chuckles)
- You know, and so,
being able to do bed management
through admissions and
discharge in real time.
And while it sounds foolish to sit here
and talk about it today,
when you think about
how money moves and everything else,
that was eye-popping,
but it was the result
of everything being done in
silos as a defined project.
And so, I think this was the first time,
you know, for our agency
where there was a true
collaborative negotiation around,
all right, what is our vision
and where do we really want to go?
So that was, for me, you know,
it was a true appreciation
for what Deloitte brought to the table,
what our AWS partners brought.
And then, you know,
without VITA, you know,
being there to support us along the way,
we would not have, you know,
been able to get this program
out the way we did, so.
- And we did undertake
an AWS review as well
in multiple stages of the architecture,
the proposed direction
and made sure we were
bouncing things off of them
of what we were doing
and how they thought that that lined up
either with particular services.
There was definitely a
financial operations,
a FinOps structure to this
to say, does this match up
to what our anticipated burn
and budget was expected to be?
And are there things
that we have to adjust
around how we're going to ingest data
or how we utilize that
information or those services
to align with the budget and the plan?
So, there was a lot of
kind of back and forth
to make sure that all lined
up that particular way.
And then a lot of requests
from, like, Bob's team
of, like, do we have the right access?
Do we have the right
people who have access?
And do we know what those
roles are supposed to be?
And do we make sure that
those roles are only using
the things that they're supposed to use?
So, it was a, you know, continues to be.
We've gone live.
We have had two of the
phases completed so far.
We are in production.
We do have two more phases
that are going with
additional data sources
and additional services
that are coming through.
So, those are some more
features to come up,
but we continue to even iterate now
and make sure that we're keeping
and maintaining that spirit
of learning from all the
things that we're doing.
- And so, this journey,
as we kinda lead into the
panel discussion here,
this journey was years in the making
when we actually started
with laying the infrastructure
components, Bob,
that, you know, your
team and you helped lead
to the implementation of
the data warehouse itself.
I think as we head into
kind of the questions
that I'm gonna ask you here
in this panel discussion.
I think, Bob, maybe
this is to you first is,
you know, from that initial vision, right?
How did you get,
like, how did you get forward?
What was the next step from the vision
to making some forward progress
to achieve that vision?
- You know, I think it
starts with having a vision.
I mean, having a leader
in an agency like Russell
to come in and bring in that background
from the private sector and say
that I have a different idea
of how we should be operating.
You know, if you look at
state government in general,
it tends to be a little stale
and people know what they know.
And many places within state
government people have been
in position for 20, 30, I mean, 40 years.
You know, I had one
person who hit 55 years,
which is just incredible, you know.
And so, they don't necessarily know
what they don't know.
And so, you need to
have people that come in
to have an alternative view
on how to accomplish the
mission much more effectively.
And they can serve as a catalyst
to the enterprise to say,
"How do we do things differently?"
Because otherwise, for someone at my level
who's trying to provide capabilities
that are then consumed by the agencies,
I am innovating for
the sake of innovating.
I need a partner in the
agencies who can lead the charge
and really push ahead
and say that there's a
different alternative
that we have to accomplish that mission.
And so, you know, we were really lucky
to find that in Russell.
So, he brought that.
That pushed us to then step forward
and say, "Now, how do we
meet that demand signal
that's now been given
and how do we work
together in order to do it
in a safe, effective,
secure way, you know,
to really advance the
state of the art forward?"
- Russell, what do you think about that?
What was your experience like
before entering state government
and how did that change when you did?
- You know, I kind of touched
on it earlier, you know,
for the organizations that I
managed in the private sector,
you owned everything.
So, life was easy, you know,
in regards to the inner
organization collaboration.
Innovating here was exciting for me
because it was a new challenge
and it really started with you changing
the culture of thinking,
you know, really working
across multiple agencies
and getting, you know, people
to see things differently,
to see how, you know,
technology wasn't a burden,
but an enabler and really
kind of driving that home.
And then really over the last
two years as we have moved
so many workloads out to
AWS when everyone said,
"You can't do that."
You know, that was the
first thing when I joined
was everyone was like,
"You're not gonna do that."
And that's always been my challenge is
as soon as you tell me
I can't do something,
that's what we're gonna get it done.
And it's just around,
you know, leading people,
you know, down a path where,
you know, you empower them,
you teach them, you mentor them.
And really it was, like I said,
it was really around teaching people
how to think differently
to drive that modernization,
to help them see
what they really wanted
to see in the systems
because, you know, they had
been doing it for so long
that they had blinders on.
- Yeah.
And Bob, I mean, back to you, I mean,
any other points you'd have
for other states or agencies
that are looking at similar
modernization goals?
How do you get them started?
- I think it's always hard
to be first, you know.
And for someone to kind of break the ice,
start moving forward, it seems,
I mean, the cloud seems
so scary in a lot of ways.
I know this is fairly common
probably for a lot of people
in the audience there.
They're probably well
along their cloud journey,
but when the state government,
where people are used to
operating a certain way,
they have these internal barriers
on reasons why they can't do it.
And so, this is where we
look at agency leadership,
enterprise leadership,
industry leadership, you know,
from like Deloitte and
others to come in and say,
"You know, there's a different
way of getting this work done
and we're holding ourselves back
and so we need to step forward, you know."
And that's where
leadership really comes in
to where leaders really know the way,
they show the way, they go the way,
and really don't accept no for an answer.
I mean, you have to be stubborn.
You have to say, "Hey, we're
gonna do this," you know,
and, you know, and the
fact of the matter is.
And then once you accomplish
it, then it's done.
And then it's no longer
a first of its kind
within the state.
It's something that is normal.
And so, we recreate that new normal.
And then what's exciting
is not just what's happening
at DBHDS at that agency,
but it's what's happening around DBHDS.
And this is other agencies
because we all talk, you know.
We're a pretty chatty bunch, you know,
the state agencies get together
and we talk about each other quite a lot
and learning from each
other and trying to say,
"Hey, you know what, maybe
I could try this too.
Maybe that I'll take a risk
and do something differently
and try to take advantage of
some of these technologies
that maybe, you know,
the enterprise is not
necessarily a challenge,
that it is possible to innovate at scale."
And once services have been
approved, that's been secured,
we've shown that pattern
that now we're just talking
about replicating it, you know,
and then it becomes a
little bit much more common.
And then as you bring
technologists together
and they start looking at these ways,
it becomes a lot more exciting.
And 'cause who really
wants to do the same thing
over and over again?
This becomes a whole
new area of innovation.
And I think that's where
the excitingness comes from
in a lot of what we do.
- Yeah.
Let's switch to tooling for a second.
I know, Russell, we've
had many discussions
around the right tools and products
to be applying in our implementation
of the data warehouse,
but kind of what were some of the things
that drove you to make decisions
around COTS versus SaaS versus
custom and native services?
Can you speak to that bit?
- I mean, I think, you know,
first and foremost, you know,
typically you look for those
revenue differentiators.
That's where your secret sauce is.
Those are the things
that you're gonna kind
of build on your own.
Those things that, you know,
are just kind of standard
across the industry.
I know, you know, we
leveraged, you know, Mirth
to do a lot of our, you
know, data translation.
You know, it just made
sense from that perspective.
Obviously, you know, using
Snowflake as our data warehouse,
as we talk about the
interagency collaborations,
there's a lot of chatter now
around the data clean rooms
and how we can begin sharing data
across the agencies in a
safe and secure manner.
So, that's where we're now
enabled with that, you know,
the data lake journey with
the AWS services, you know,
where we get, you know, full-blown,
you know, ODS out there,
up and running is gonna be great.
So, from that perspective,
we really wanted to stay,
you know, as cutting edge as we could
with our AWS, you know,
services and capabilities,
you know, the event-driven architecture
that, you know, we're kind
of doing in partnership
with you all is really going to enable us.
We got change data capture
capabilities, you know,
on the docket to really
kind of drive, you know,
how fast we can move data, you know,
throughout the state when it
comes to health information.
And really all of this kind
of sets us up for the future
of a health information
exchange, you know,
in the state of Virginia
where we can really,
really, you know, empower,
you know, how people are treated
and serviced across the state.
- Thank you. So, we have to talk about AI.
Don, why don't you reflect
on kind of what's ahead
with how we could be
looking to incorporate
artificial intelligence in this solution?
- Yeah, I think that a lot
of the initial focus had been
on how do we get to the data
and then how do we enable the department
to start analyzing the data?
So, AI had not been a real
strong focus from the outset,
but now I think that the
agency is starting to realize
that there is a lot of information.
There's a lot of very detailed information
and how can they use that.
For any of you who are
sort of the health tech care
standards nerds in the room,
like the HL7 structure itself,
the evolution into fire is
continuously changing as well.
It's continuing to evolve.
And as we start moving into
maintenance mode associated
with the data warehouse and the ingestion,
the integration engine,
those things will also need
to continue to maintain
and keep up with those
changes as they occur.
And so part of the maintenance
and operations process,
start of the process of looking
at how those changes
are evolving is using AI
to help with the coding process,
to keep pace with those changes.
Whether it's from the companion guides,
whether it's from the
implementation guides,
evolving standards themselves,
to then say we can automate
the addition of fields
in the EDT message.
We can automate those fields
coming from the community service boards
because they're going to
review them every year
and start looking at what
additional information
or what changing information are they.
So, how do we enable AI to support that
and speed up the automation process there?
The second thing as well that
we're also looking at now is,
with that unprecedented information,
the department can start to
become much more proactive
of looking at that and saying
generation of alerts in
the continuum of care
and saying, "This person
has been readmitted.
This is the third time
in the last six months
that they've been readmitted.
We're seeing that these specific symptoms,
these specific triggers,
and now we can say we
have particular facilities
that we can start looking
at proactively saying
treatment patterns and
things for those individuals
can happen because of the
sheer amount of information
that's available about them
and the treatment that's happening."
So, I think I'm very excited.
I hope the department's very excited,
about now starting to get out
in front of these things
that are happening.
I think that also helps the
department start looking at,
how much do those services cost?
Do they have a good understanding
of what drivers are behind
procedures and diagnosis
and state hospitals
and services that drive
what those costs are going to be or are
and that sort of things
that they can start predicting
out, doing budget forecasting
and using AI to start looking at that
of where are they seasonal variations,
where are there other
things that are driving
what some of those particular areas are.
So, I think it's an exciting world now.
We've talked a bit more
about how we can use prompts
and various things within
chat box functions for people
who are asking questions about
the analytics themselves,
the drivers behind the metrics,
the number of people that are within it,
without having to physically
code or drag and drop in,
you know, semantic layers for BI systems.
And I know, Russell, you and
I talked a long time ago about
how can we start enabling some
of these models that have,
through these APIs can
create and generate alerts
that immediately go out from them
and they can be embedded in any system.
It doesn't have to go to the warehouse.
The warehouse serves as
that function of the data
and then the things that it finds,
it can create alerts to other systems.
It can send alerts out
to, you know, care measures or otherwise.
And so I think there's a
lot of great possibilities
that we're just on the cusp of.
- [Bryant] Bob, anything
you wanna add to that?
- No, I'm good.
(all laughing)
- Russell. Okay.
- One other area that, you know,
we actually partner with one
of the local universities
to actually write the
curriculum for the course.
And there's usually about
six to seven students
that are in this advanced course.
This is our recruiting pipeline.
This is how we're bringing in
the new talent that we need.
And so, this semester that just wrapped up
and they just actually
presented to us last week,
was using agentic AI to actually
improve overall metadata
as we're bringing, you know,
data into the data warehouse.
So that will be a component
that we actually get to keep
within the agency.
So, semester over
semester, they get to build
new innovative solutions for the agency
and then we get to hopefully hire
those very smart young
adults into our agency
and keep our talent
pipeline moving as well, so.
- [Bryant] Keep the mic.
Let me ask you now to rewind this back to,
if you had to go through this journey
from the start all over again,
what advice would you
give for other agencies
trying to pull together
the right partners,
the right resources, the
right funding channels
to assemble a team to take
on such an initiative?
- I think, first and foremost,
you know, for me, you know,
I have a very large network
and it was about bringing in people
that wanted to do something
different in their careers.
And we'd all been at the grind, you know,
at Fortune 500 companies.
We've been modernizing for decades now.
And, you know, I kind of joked, you know,
with the leaders at the agency
that I felt like it was
time that I gave back.
And so, I think it's really
around how do you bring in
a team of individuals that
wants to change something.
And so, that was, you know,
I think I was two months
into my role, you know,
Bob was rolling out some cloud stuff
and I sent him an email and I said,
"I've got some thoughts."
And so, he was like,
and this was over the Christmas holiday-
- And then it began.
- And then it began, yeah.
(panelists laughing)
And he said, "Let's meet
that first week of January."
And it went in and it felt
more like an interview.
- Yeah.
- And so, it was really
me laying out the vision
of kind of what I wanna do.
So, I think in anything that you do,
you have to have a vision,
then you have to have people
that understand your vision
and wanna be a part of it,
and then people that can
actually build a strategy
and then go execute on it.
And then it's around motivating.
I mean, this journey when we
were, you know, building out,
you know, what our
future architecture was,
what our, you know, roadmap
for modernizing was,
we were, you know,
upskilling all of our staff.
I mean, we had, you know,
within the first six months
of starting this journey,
there were over 60 individuals,
you know, that had received
numerous AWS certifications.
I had never seen anything like
that in the private sector.
People were excited, you know.
For the first time, it was
like we were not only building
a modernization roadmap,
but we were building a career roadmap
for people, you know, and individuals
of how they were gonna
advance their careers.
And so, I think it was
just building that energy.
And then as Bob had indicated, you know,
we work closely together
with our sister agencies
and really everybody is
now beginning to see.
And these components that
we're building division
is reusability, you know.
And we really want to
be able to start laying
all of this stuff out, you know,
so that other agencies can
come along and leverage it
and begin to move faster, you know,
within the state of Virginia.
- And I was gonna to add on
just a little bit to that,
'cause you talked about reusability
and one thing that we didn't
get too far into earlier was
you mentioned Mirth and kind
of the integration engine.
And part of that process
is of course you have APIs,
the EHRs, they submitted
those HL7 messages.
Mirth is an integration engine,
processes them and does
all the acknowledgements
and various things that
come out that process.
But the core of that is that it outputs
what is the finalized,
cleansed, you know, message
that is going to be stored in an S3 bucket
and then made available
to DBHDS as the whole
for various applications as
well as the data warehouse.
And I remember, you know,
very distinct conversations
with Russell of, okay,
I may not like Mirth.
I know it's a commercial product.
Like, fine, it is what it is.
As long as it is encapsulated in its thing
and it's API enabled,
and that way at any point
in time if I need to,
I can replace it with
something else, right?
I can take constituent parts of this
and allow it to be future-proof
so that if things change
and evolve over time,
I'm not locked into something
that these services, this
enablement is going to allow me
to evolve and grow and
change with this over time,
versus the pain of, like,
oh, I'm locked into this specific tool,
or I'm locked into licensing for something
and now it's gonna, I
have to keep it that way
because that's what it is.
And I think that was a really
big theme that we worked on
when you talked about tools and software
and structure and architecture.
And I think we've gotten
ourselves a pretty good way
down that path to keep it
as much to that as we can.
- Yeah.
- [Bryant] What other challenges
did you hit along the way
that others might benefit from navigating
in their implementations?
- Well, I think a little bit
of, at least in my opinion,
was some of the unknown.
There wasn't a specific template.
I mean, we had our
suggestion, we had our pathway
that we were gonna move forward with
and sort of working through with VITA
of, like, where do we set it up?
How do we make requests?
How do we define the
roles that are for those?
A lot of that had not really
been done at this scale before.
And so, for DBHDS, for us,
for VITA, it was a, like,
we need to talk about how
we do all of those things.
And if we're in certain environments,
only certain DBHDS architects
are gonna have access
at an administrator level to those things
and our team would not.
So, then how does the handoff of,
there's an issue, who do I call?
Or how do I put in a ticket?
And so, many of those things
had not been defined or decided yet.
And we were all learning
along the way to get to that,
you know, that sort of was what it was,
wasn't necessarily
anybody's fault or anything,
but it was, we gotta
all get on the same page
and have lots of conversations around,
it's not gonna just be us.
As more things come as
other projects happen,
as other things happen
with VITA and with DBHDS,
they're gonna need these too.
So let's establish those patterns now
and sort of cement them
of how we think they're going to work.
- [Bryant] Yep.
So, what's coming up next?
Bob, why don't you take that?
What's ahead for VITA?
- Sure.
You know, as we talked about earlier,
the idea is that we
want to create patterns.
We want to create different
solutions and, you know,
and in the way citizens
experience state government,
they don't experience
it through an agency.
They experience it as a problem set
that they're trying to solve against.
And so, you look at the
challenges that we have
and there are some real
challenges out there, you know,
and one of the things
we're combating right now
is the use of opioids,
you know, substance abuse.
And unfortunately, there's a
lot of it out there, you know.
And so, you look at at how do we tackle
some of these problems
that are really not
single agency problems?
And what we have found
was that there needs to be
a structure to provide solutions
that can pull in multiple
agencies together,
'cause agencies are really good
about doing agency missions.
I mean, they're optimized
for those missions,
but when you want to elevate
a problem to a higher level
and say, "You know, we
have something, an issue
that's really spanning
across multiple agencies,
then it becomes a little bit
more of a challenging set."
And so, this is an example of a solution
that we've developed separate from DBHDS,
even though DBHDS is one of
the participating agencies
working with our partners
at Deloitte to build out
a substance use disorder,
an abatement platform.
It's called SUDA
but this pulls in data
from 10 different agencies.
It puts together into
different visualizations
to understand, and it's designed
to really serve the frontline workers
that are throughout the state,
people that are operating
in law enforcement,
people operating in behavioral
health and social services,
and people operating in the localities
at all these different levels
to give them information
to understand what is going on statewide.
And so, there you're able to
see usage around substance use,
you're able to understand
trends and patterns.
It looks at data.
Nothing like this exists in the nation.
And so we're very proud of
the work that we're doing.
And the thing is about
creating solutions like this
is that once you've done
it, you can do it again.
Because there are other challenges
that are multi-agency challenges,
challenges around workforce development,
challenges around education,
challenges around permitting,
challenges around putting people to work
and business development and
all these different things
that are critically important.
All the things you need to create a state
that is the best place to
live, work, and raise a family.
Those are all the things that
citizens really care about.
And so, they don't care about
what agency is doing a particular thing.
And so, as we look at how to
elevate these conversations
and elevate these solutions,
I think that's where
there's a lot of opportunity
for us to do better.
And so, using platforms
like AWS to kind of serve
as that foundational technology,
having leaders like Russell here
to talk about different ways
of doing things differently
to really explore the boundaries
of what we're capable
of doing and find people
that are willing to look
at a bigger mission.
You know, that's why people
come to state government.
It's really all about the mission.
We care about our
neighbors and our friends
and the people we live and work with,
and we wanna do better for them.
And so, that's what makes state government
really, really exciting.
- [Bryant] I agree. Thank you.
Folks, we've left some time
to ask your own questions.
For those of you that
are also on this journey
of innovation, if you have questions,
I think we've got a mic set up
or we have a runner
here, so please ask away.
- [Audience Member] Yeah, I'd love to hear
a little bit more about how you,
you said earlier that
you're bringing in sources,
not just from different agencies
but also maybe even private
practices and things like that.
How do you deal with some
of the sharing information
and the legality of that?
How did you navigate the
kind of the constraints
around sharing data, health
data across different groups?
- Want to take that.
Yeah, that's a difficult one there.
It's interesting coming
outta the private sector
and understanding, you know,
all the data rules and regulations.
It's magnified at the state level.
And so, these data clean rooms
that I mentioned earlier
is one of the areas
that we're moving into where,
you know, we can really begin
to control who has access
to what levels of data.
That's one aspect.
The other things that we are doing is
there's a lot of data work
and anonymization that's happening
across the agency as well
where we've been able
to, you know, work with
the universities once again
to introduce noise into
data sets to really begin
to anonymize, you know, the data
from that perspective as well.
And then that way we've also built out
using AWS a data synthetic generator,
so we can literally take true data sets
and then mock them up in a way
where I can completely scrub the data
but still leave it in its normal state
so you can do analytics on it.
So, that's another avenue
that we've gone down as well
to kind of begin to safely
share data out, you know,
across, you know, our
sister agencies as well.
- Yeah, also-
- Thank you.
- At the point of ingestion,
since we have unique submitter IDs
based on the community service board,
we also have very
definitive security roles
within the ingestion process to identify
who they're aligned to and
who they're associated with,
because those are the parties
that are also allowed to see
that particular detail level information.
So, all of those are also built in
to all of the downstream processing.
It's associated with the data
everywhere from, you know,
the point that it's ingested
to the point that it's dropped
to the point that it's made available
into the synthetic or
into the semantic layer,
and then as well into the end dashboards
that people are able to see.
So, that community service
board can only see their members
and who they're aligned
to and then the messages
for a certain period of
time that go back for them.
So, there's a lot of
role-based access work
that goes into that at the message level.
- Yeah, and just to,
one of the other things
that we didn't touch on here today was,
through this data warehouse journey,
the agency was rolling
out data governance.
And so, while most of you
all have probably, you know,
rolled this out, you know,
in your professional careers,
there was no concept of
a data owner, a steward,
or a custodian at the agency.
And so, data governance was rolled out
over the last two years as well.
And we are now using the universal,
the SageMaker Universal Studio
to begin building out data
dashboards for the data owners
to understand not only data quality,
but that's gonna be the
governance mechanism
of who they can actually provide access
to their data sets as well.
So that's just one of the mechanisms
that we've done as well.
- Just wanna add a little bit to it.
I do want to assure everybody
that the security of data
is really important, you know.
And so, we're regulated by a
number of different bodies.
There's HIPAA data that's
regulated, you know,
health and human services data.
There's CJIS data, which
is criminal justice data
that regulates our law
enforcement agencies.
There's FERPA data that
regulates our educational data.
All of these data sources
are held at the agency level
because they're the
ones who best understand
the constraints and the
requirements of their data.
So, Russell certainly
representing the data at DBHDS
and there are people like Russell
at each of the different
agencies that hold data.
I mean, that's a challenge,
but it's also an opportunity
of how do we create mechanisms
to share things safely and securely.
So, I don't want to give the impression
that hey, we take it all
and just kind of throw
it into a great big room
and that everybody just kind
of has that citizen data.
That is not the case at all,
that this stuff is very,
very tightly locked down,
sometimes too excessively so,
but we take that very seriously.
Cybersecurity data protection
is a key missionary
of the state because we do
hold the role that we have
of being custodians of citizen
data extremely seriously.
So, that's part of what we do.
- [Bryant] Thank you. Other questions?
- [Audience Member] Yeah,
I was curious if you have
or are using any level of
SDOH to determine propensity
for service needs?
- So, we have talked about integration
from some additional sources.
We do have some external lines,
but we have not delved very
far into social determinants
of health data sets.
We've been examining what
some of the best ones are
in relation to the information
that they have now as a wealth of them,
especially some of the
propensity around supporting
more of the demographic
information that's not available
through, you know, the service delivery
aspect of the messages.
But I think that's something
they're starting to bridge now
with the department of what
are those externalized sets?
Where do we pull them down from?
How do we curate what they are?
How do we link them together
with the existing data that they have?
So, it's part of the journey is just,
I think it's something
that we're starting off on.
- [Staff] Next one's right here.
- [Audience Member] I just
had a quick question about
how you've used the system
with the implementation
of Marcus Alerts in Virginia
and how the coordination
between the behavioral
health data ingestion
and the PSAP CAD center 911 stuff
has worked with you guys' system.
- What was the second part? I'm sorry.
With behavioral health
with relation to what?
- [Audience Member] 911 centers.
- Oh, 911 centers. Oh, okay, gotcha.
Okay.
- Okay, so you're talking about PSAPs.
Those are the call centers
operate, take 911 call.
And those are operated
at the locality level.
Now, there is an organization,
the Virginia Department
of Emergency Management
that has governance across,
what we call Next Generation 911.
And that allows interoperability
between the various 911 call centers.
So, if one center goes down,
other center is able to step up,
but each one operates
in a particular region.
They do take the call.
They're able to dispatch
first responders to that area
and provide the citizen
with the help that they need
in order to secure the
safety of all involved.
But the data is really
held at the locality level.
So there is not a necessarily
a mechanism to merge that data
beyond the record.
Now, once there is an
interaction with the citizen,
the patient, they do generate a record.
That record does then flow in through
what we call the office of EMS.
They then take that
record to have awareness
of what's happening on a
statewide basis, you know.
So, we know within 24
hours every single call
that happened in the state.
So, it's pretty cool.
- I think right now what
we're looking in particular at
is that the health event
itself could identify somebody
who may have come in because
they've been unconscious.
But I think the tie is
what we're trying to get to now around.
There was a call that was
made particularly about that,
which had a responder
that came then to it,
which is the reason why that
person ended up in a facility
or otherwise with the
situation that they're in.
So, there are some definitive
data matching rules
that we use in particular
to try to completely match those up.
I think that's an algorithm
that we continue to look
at and its efficacy.
It's one of the things that
Russell had also mentioned
of putting out something in
front of those data stewards
to say these match
levels, whether we believe
that they're corresponding accurately
with the things that
we're matching them on,
and is that the right level
of matching that we're trying to get to.
But it is still, I
think, an ongoing process
around how accurate is that
with where the data sets
that we're trying to match up.
- [Bryant] Any other
questions from the group?
All right, stunned silence.
- Yay.
- Okay.
We'll stick around for a few minutes after
in case there's some other followups
that you'd all would
like to have in person.
And thank you everyone for showing up and-
(audience applauding)
- Yeah. Thank you.
- Thank you to the panel today.